[Music]
welcome
to our simply learned webinar how
data science can help the postcovid
world recover
with dr santanu tarya and
chief data scientist of airtel
uh more about him in a moment so with
that
i'd like to introduce fontana welcome
uh hi okay
i was gonna say yeah forgive me if i
mangle your last name but uh dr suntanu
bachchara is the chief data scientist
of airtel um he's been in roles in data
science and product at facebook
aol time warner and various startup
companies
um one of the most fascinating things
about his career is that he got his phd
at nasa's goddard space flight center
and he is an alumni of
uh mit sloan and the mit media lab
so welcome thank you stuart and welcome
everyone who is joining from around the
world
it's an honor and a privilege to have an
opportunity to chat with you
some of you might some of you might look
it up early in the
day some of you are catching up towards
probably the later part of the day
thank you thank you so much for joining
us so this is going to be a conversation
and i've got a few questions along the
way to guide us
um first how can data science
help control the health impacts of code
of cognitive
19 all right stuart am i
uh audible yes you are that he could not
hear anything
absolutely all right so that's an
example it's usually
no it's not autumn okay all right
all righty as long as it's not me um
so you know as you all know our life has
changed in the past few months
on the morning of january first
you when you woke up uh from the uh hard
parties
at uh at wherever you are on that day
most of you woke up
you had not imagined a world that would
be so different today
lives have been deserved around the
globe uh in india for example
we think the estimate is around 140
million people have lost their
livelihood temporarily globally they
estimate uh by
who uh un and so on
is up to a billion people could
potentially lose their livelihood
the world has gone through a change that
only happens once it's out of 100 years
the last one was the spanish flu of 1918
1919 so it's roughly about 100
or so right so what do you need to do
now that we are in the middle of it now
that we are
spending a great lot of time figuring
out what the
um remedies are what the medicines are
multiple
multiple multiple vaccines on trial
simultaneously around the globe
the last count i heard was 23
simultaneous trials going on that are
known as the national level or at a
large company level
i'm sure there are 50 hundred more at a
lab at a university level and more
so what do you need to do stuart we
really need to do and figure out two
aspects of this question
the first one i call is the people
places and livelihoods
right uh what it really means right you
especially have now people
who are being infected at an alarming
rate please like india be
still going up in eu it's sort of
gone up gone through the peak and going
down in the u.s
my other country which is where i spent
most of my life it's still going up
so you need to figure out a way of
figuring out who are the people
um who are being impacted and how do you
model that world right
the the multiple ways of doing it today
there are contract tracing apps
that are being employed around the world
um the
my uh the other alma and where i still
work mit
there's a product called safe path which
enables you to do basic contract tracing
it's the fundamental of
doing contra tracing using a privacy
preserve
you know maintaining all aspects of
privacy which is if
um you're not infected you don't get to
see who you are in contact with because
that would be a major violation of
privacy
in india we have arugula setup which is
uh probably the first public service app
in the planet
which had 100 billion download so all
the efforts are essentially going on
right now
to figure out the people and how they
are they how
distressing right um the second aspect
of
is what i call is the places now people
live in places people working places
um true
is as we sort of try to contain this bed
we are trying to figure out what are the
safe places today tomorrow
what are the ways um the places that are
going to go through
the two go through two things right one
is the wave of infection
and second is the wave of places it will
go from one place to another place no
matter unless you are locking
everyone down inside their house it's
going to go to from one place to another
place
so there are some beautiful tools um
that are available in the market uh
someone just said i'm not audible am i a
reboot store
you are to me yes okay awesome
uh so some of the tools that are
available today sorry
just look at the web traffic data i'm
browsing i'm chanting
i'm browsing uh my uh on my phone today
in bangalore tomorrow in another place
200 miles from bangalore
with the help of the googles and the
facebook
and many of the telcos around the world
we can actually get the movement data
and these help in beautiful way in
figuring out
how the diseases are you know in this
modeling world right
how the diseases are going to spread
from one place to another place
what are the future likelihood of the
wave
of the disease uh in different places
right
the third bucket of it eventually um
you know as painful as um
sad it may be eventually you have to go
and make a livelihood
you cannot be in this situation forever
maybe three months maybe six months you
can be in the lockdown
so what are you calling the safe unlock
down and data signs
can play a massive role in that when you
talk think about
unlock down what do you do very simple
example suppose you're opening
a factory in chennai which is about a
couple of hundred miles from here
the automotive hub of india just like
dearborn michigan in the u.s right
are now more of the southern states when
did you unlock down so think of couple
of things right
um there's a factory where they are
trying to now get 6000 people in
in every shift now if you want to do the
standard way of measuring ambulance
temperature
and uh you know making sure that they're
wearing masks and making sure
they're maintaining safe distance
letting in six thousand people you
estimated will take about four hours
half the shift will be over by the time
the people are checking in in the new
way
so how do you build that automated
process right uh
you build essentially one solution would
be you build a
vision model which looks at your body
temperature through a higher camera
right higher camera it ensures you're
wearing a mask
you are ensured that you're maintaining
a safe distance as you are entering the
factory
and automatically lets you scan through
without touching anything
um then in that process what we found
out
about 70 to 80 percent of the check-in
process can be done automatically
so that would be and you know without
interrupting the flow of the people
and the flow of the work right so these
are some of the new nails that will come
up you have to literally
rethink your business the way you have
been sort of conducting business on a
day-to-day basis is going to change
rapidly
more and more data science models in a
world that's contactless
in a world where the hygiene is the
premium in a world where you have to
maintain social distancing
you have to one idea of the data science
that will sort of just explode is what
i'll call the vision science right
a lot of the stuff will be automatically
monitored checked in
uh sops would be cleared safety level
would be determined
and if you are not going to be safe in
that workplace it will be automatically
flat out
so this is the people places and
livelihood the second bucket
is essentially in the water college and
this is an ecology epidemiological
modeling
that's where data science is playing a
massive role today
i'm not at i work with some of them in
terms of providing the
data sets that we have i also have an
academic background so i work with
folks in academics uh some aware of it
right um so using the public health
information the epidemiological
information uh and figuring out
how simple how the disease will spread
that itself is an
important information that allows the
government
and the other agencies to figure out
where to move your resources where to
get the doctors and nurses
how do you uh stuff your hospital right
how do you get the supplies
uh in different parts of the country if
you're going to find out that
in the state of uh
or taking a u.s example in the state of
california
they are going to be 122 hotspot and i'm
just making up these numbers
and these then you move your medical
supplies accordingly so the first one is
just the
diesel movement the second bucket is
given
a lot of the tricks that are said 23
different types of treatments are being
tried out
that's at least in the large public
domain and probably in hundreds
and hundreds of sets of different types
of vacuum practices right
take that data build models and figure
out which are
ones uh for the time being very for uh
combating the disease right you would
also
look at the healthcare delivery right
now you know where the disease is
spreading you also know that
the uh balls are being built to you know
predict success which
medicine should be or which vaccine
should be likely to be successful in
what the processes you would call
or for the treatments right on top of
that you lay around the delivery aspect
of rig
if you can figure out and it touched
upon it few seconds a few minutes back
if you can predict what the resources
need to be allocated because
one of our biggest challenges don't have
infinite resources one of the things
that the whole world is struggling with
today
is the resources are far less than that
what you are facing
so unless you do intelligent resource
allocation you are not going to be able
to
minimize the impact of the disease so
these are a couple of the areas that i
think
where data science can play great roles
yeah and one of the things that
you kind of touched on in terms of
treatment analysis is
uh you know some of the the
work that's being done in
pharmacology where they're modeling
different
compounds and trying to use
artificial intelligence data science to
test them in a virtual way rather than
um on individuals
and come up with suggestions for maybe
this drug that's already on the market
is valuable in the kovit fight so
it's a really fascinating area
but let's ask another question
because this is an important part of
what you discussed
how can data science help companies
recover lost business and reinvent
themselves
because that's crucial for people making
a living
for the employees of those companies to
be able to go back to work
absolutely as i said i touched upon it
on the last question saying that look
at the end of the day if you cannot
rebuild the livelihoods
you would end up causing far more
distress around the world than you've
already cost right this is going to
cause far more distress around the world
than it has already crossed
you have to be able to figure out to
rebuild the livelihoods and you're not
the only way to rebuild the livelihood
other than the disease prevention and
all of that stuff
is essentially letting business come
back to an extent
uh where they become operational uh
you know figure out the products and
services that people are going to buy
and in that process um reinvent
themselves right
so i would this is an interesting area
for data scientists this is an area
where not comfortably
you know what's our best sort of comfort
zone our comfort zone is someone tells
us what to do
and you go and build that model right
right someone says that look i need to
reach out
you know you know my world right i need
to reach out
to 50 000 people uh in the state of
karnataka who is going to change the
handset
so i can run a campaign now i go build a
handstand upgrade model
in my world of telco right i run a
campaign i'm very happy
someone told me what to do right so this
is this
this product and there's a data science
we come sort of on the back end
um think of this being uh the bmw car
designers right
someone told us that you need a 550
horsepower engine
uh you know turbocharged and it should
be fully efficient right
aspect you know in a bmw is not that
important yet
but once that's done it's we have the
like the bmw car uh
engine the engine um engine designers
right
we are very good in going in the corner
and figuring out the best engine the
planet can build
however we sort of have to get in on
comfort zone today
we have to start reimagining the word
the world where the businesses will
operate from tomorrow so there
are i would say three or four aspects of
that world
that world is going to be driven by
social distancing
right that word is driven by
constant hygiene practices mask hand
washing
all of that that world is going to be
contactless
right or minimal contact and
consequently all of that is going to
move digital
so i'll give an example at uh you know
at airtel where we i work at the chief
data scientist
i am the it's one of world's largest
telcos we recently started redoing our
stores as the digital store
while you walk in and you've got this
beautiful uh
you know the tv tables where you can
touch you know do a lot of your
uh activities there for example you can
pay the bills without seeing a person in
your sales store
you can pay your bills you can upgrade
your plan you can
you know get a information on new
handsets you can watch a piece of
content
that you're offering all of that stuff
look at our new products
it's a tough screen table and you play
with it
and we spend a great deal of time effort
and money rebuilding the stores a large
number of stores
guess what happens in a world where
hygiene is the premium
are you now going to go scrub that
surface of that uh
touch screen every single time anyone
touches it because
ideally that's what you should do and
that will probably rub off the elements
in a very quick time and it will make
the whole thing uh useless
you have to reimagine how to rebuild
that world right
so think of any business that you're in
sort of start thinking like a product
person as opposed to
a just a data science person right that
when the hygiene becomes the premium
right
um is that something the customer is
looking to ask yourself perversion is
something customer is looking for is
this something the customer
will uh willingly pay for so i'll give
you two examples of recently a friend of
mine
went for a tooth extraction uh
to uh his dentists so in india tooth
extractions relatively in the normal
ones are relatively cheaper
it's about 2500 rupees in a big city
which is about 35
the person ended up paying out of 700
rupees which is rather ten dollars which
is
30 off the fee of the tooth extraction
as a hygiene fee because the dentist the
dental assistant
and uh you know and the patient
all three are in ppp people sorry pp
someone has to pay for it right um
i had the same experience just recently
when i had a
dental crown installed and they charge
an extra 25
specifically for the ppe absolutely
in fact i'll tell you this right um i
come from a part of india called bengal
near the ocean
and we cannot live without fish the guy
who's selling me fish
he does the delivery so if you buy
beyond certain amounts say about twenty
dollars the delivery is free
free but it has
thing about 30 cents as a hygiene fee
so when your fish guy is charging your
hygienic you realize the world is going
to change
the world is going to change uh almost
permanently right
so how do you in a hygiene world so
think of the
you know a retail store right what
are you used to doing you are used to
going to a retail store you are used to
trying out clothes and then buying the
ones you want
is that in if you are going to be a data
scientist
who predicts the sales page of the
printing surprising
that's the part of the behavior you
never taken into
uh taken into consideration right now if
people are not allowed to try
your clothes right they have to buy it
either buy it
or not buy it how do you how does your
cell phone model now work
right you really have to start thinking
about what it calls the signals
and parameters you've never dealt with
right now
right i'm making it sound like it's a
gloomy word right
there are going to be opportunities for
creating new sources of revenue
one as i just said is a hygiene fee
right would people
pay for now a version of the world where
if you make it contactless if you make
it
really super hygienic when they pay for
it right
maybe the two dollars you're trying to
make out of a 30
piece of jeans that is your net it is
okay in profit right
maybe you can tack on another dollar as
a high gp and you can
provide really visual hygienic outcomes
to your business right
so we think this model our data
scientists
can us data scientists cannot be sitting
in a macro world anymore
you have to really start thinking all
our models would go for a toss
the model that you built yesterday ah my
guess is that i was sitting down and
writing down the 30 common
models in you know two or three fields
banking
uh retail uh you know those are the two
biggest ones that uses their size today
and my guess is about 30 of the models
that we are building today
will actually have to be rebuilt because
of the way the world has changed
right very simple your pricing and
sell-through rate
itself will go through a toss if you
don't consider the change behavior of
the customers
yeah and a lot of things that were
developed
uh in the last several years on the
basis of
people will want this as a convenience
have now taken the forefront as
people need to do this because of
hygienic reasons
um i was always reluctant to use the
feature
of depositing a check with my mobile
phone
um and now it's much easier to do it
that way than to try to
even go to the bank and use the atm um
to deposit a check um same thing as you
were mentioning in
retail apparel where the
applications for using your phone to
take your own measurements and do a
virtual
try on of garment was considered to be
kind of a niche
convenience thing but now it's it's much
more important
so it's a it's a very interesting
shift in the world
the next question um so
as you mentioned this is the first
global pandemic that we've had to deal
with
in a hundred years but you know
um not seen nicholas tyler is a writer
who
who came up with the phrase black swan
to describe
things that we don't
have in our minds that can happen
to disrupt our lives that we've never
seen them before
in our experience so we believe them to
be impossible but
they're possible and they happen what's
the role of data science
in preparing businesses public policy
to prepare be agile in the face of
these potential future disruption
perfect that's actually a very very good
question saying that look
whatever had to happen has happened
right how do you learn from it how do
you go forward right
um you know at the end of the day as i
said you have to have
you know take care of people you have to
take care of
safe places for them to live and work at
and you take care of their livelihood
right and you have to make
any of this happen right um you have to
sort of
go back and figure out not only um what
happened now
but what can in the future when if it
happens next time
you know god forbid you know i'm hoping
not what can you learn from here right
let me flip that question right i was i
was just going to go play that this
question of yours when i
was reading through it and said look why
um when i think about um
your question essentially says uh what
role data science is preparing business
right sometimes you don't prepare
business businesses figure
themselves out in my end
dream i would not never have never
figured out
that louis vuitton would be making masks
right
and those masks would be sold at
probably
at a reasonable profit which would not
obviously make up for living on bags
than anything else but it's not going to
be a bad one right
so one of the one of the ways is that
you know because some businesses the
reality is that some businesses will be
act very very quickly
and they will survive and they'll do
well right some businesses don't
right um and they will not
sort of uh you know make it in the
longer ride some businesses
naturally have a disadvantage i mean
thank god i
thought i would never say that thank god
i work for telco right
our data cut our data consumption is up
65
in six weeks after uh you know
between the first week of march and
middle of april
and a lot of the people who uh
in your audience might say that look and
it is true that a lot of times
the you know data is being disrupted the
call is being disrupted
but my only defense is that when the
consumption goes up by
60 percent in the middle of a lockdown
of a country where he cannot really move
a lot of people
even as though an exempted as an
emergency services
the reality is that a lot of people
could not get out of their house they
themselves were in lockdown areas
a lot of the labors move back to their
villages and so on
so when a business goes up by 60 in six
weeks in the middle of a lockdown
you know uh that's an opportunity right
um
yeah business will be an opportunity to
explain some business a little lesson if
you get out how to respond to it right
but in all of them what the one
common thing that is sort of uh
important
one of the exercises i'll do is i took a
sectoral view if i had infinite time
i'll take a spectrum
of different businesses right take the
top businesses
right financial services uh banking
uh retail transportation
uh you know food and beverage slash
hospitality
and you know dead top five right i would
actually take a spectral view of it
look at recoveries within that sector of
the subsectors within financial
services what went up quickly right
so if within financial services the
stocks and bonds recovered
right the uh and my guess is that
insurance recovered because other is now
buying health insurance in india people
who didn't consider buying henry
insurance before
in the united states also the people
when they're in the age group of 18 to
25 or 30
they consider themselves to be immortal
and were one of the lowest
in terms of buying health insurance
although i find the insurance is
recommended
so i take a sectoral view i'd look at
the data what recovered
and i'd essentially tied back to the the
social reasons
right and the um um other reasons
that led to that recovery right uh in
retail
right and i'll tell you what recovered
in india in terms of
every one today wants to be a food
delivery or a grocery delivery business
right
so what happened staying at home became
important
much less contactless became important
social distancing became
important so as a result of that there
is a sudden shift
in behavior right so i'd look at the way
i would do this i'll take a sectoral
view
off and the sixth one is my apology the
sixth one is obviously the health care
right yeah um uh i'll take a spectral
view of it
see what once we cover which one's
recovered what are the reasons for that
and essentially you sort of have a model
behavior out of that
right the reason why the i'll take your
altitude one level below that what i
just said right
the model behavior would be the reason
insurance just went through roof the
health insurance
is likely that the eighteen to thirty
year old samurai
have realized that buying an insurance
is a good idea if you're going to be
facing the pandemic for the next year or
so right
and if that's the segment that went from
being thirty percent insured to ninety
percent
sure you suddenly have the signal that
next time there's a
health related disaster this is what
might happen right
so this is the way data scientists would
uh as in terms of helping businesses
recover
and building the public policy next
let's let's go to the next one you also
public policy right
again i as a data scientist look at what
worked and what didn't work
why are you able to for example do the
spread of the disease right well
are the kind digital modeling uh models
work
are the current data inputs see a lot of
new sources of data became available for
example contract tracing you want to
think of contract testing as a were of
collecting the data
in january right by march it was known
so what are the new data sources work
what are the models what right so sort
of take the ones that are working versus
things that are not didn't work and i'll
build my repository and the toolkit for
the next one so the next time it comes
my response time is much shorter
remember had we been able to respond
faster
and it shows between countries right
countries that are able to
adopt vietnam as a country
i mean remarkable a country of i know
you know a reasonably large population
had so few cases
and after the fact it was now clear why
it happened right
so look at three things one what new
sources become
available second what type of models
that work and didn't work
and third what is the sort of what i
call is the societal
uh background right that made those
first two possible right why that
certain things work i mean for example
he could have done the business modeling
in case of vietnam and india in one case
it would have worked and in other words
it would have worked
or worked less that's because the one
had from the amount of data available
right so you can essentially you know
what i've called
is on an average a lot of things will
look like they're similar so for example
uh you know the most of the countries
the eu countries
european union countries they recovered
on an average the shape is playing
the game of it to watch as there is what
it's called as a d
they figure out because the societies
are different
at a gross level things look very
similar when you d
average you will actually end up saying
this is the most of the reasons
why things work the way they did is
because three things right one this is
availability of certain amount of data
second the social norms right some
societies are more disciplined
in terms of maintaining the high gains
maintaining their social distancing
maintaining
a lot of other things right and the
third aspect of it your
ability to go build that model that
world right if you can figure out the
average those two things i think will be
better prepared than next time than we
are
today excellent um
let's take a moment to ask another
question of the audience
and in this case it's
what data science skills are you
currently using in your work
getting a steady stream of answers
coming in goals are always fine
stewart i have a question for you as
you're doing the poll do you have a
sense of where
people are running from because the
first chat i saw on the chat box was a
gentleman or a lady i could not figure
out from the name joining from nigeria
um and that was fascinating to see
people joining from
you know many continents do you have a
sense of that
um i have a sense from previous webinars
we've done that we
get participants from
a number from the philippines from
various african countries certainly from
india
and north america as well and a few
people from europe
so we do have a global audience it's a
little bit limited by the
time zones obviously it's uh
closer to midnight in the philippines
but
it's surprising the number of people we
get from
all over the world so it's a true
global audience and i'm going to go
ahead
so the people who answered the greater
number
are involved in data analytics
and then there's a smattering across the
board
with a little blip in terms of ai and
machine learning
so let's move on to the next
question and that is
how is data science itself
going to evolve as we come out of covid
what what will
change in the field or the discipline
good question good questions twerk um
you know couple
sponsors are very very obvious right
they're things that will get prioritized
as a result of the copied uh areas of
data science that will be a priority
for example uh while i have
you know been in data science for in a
good 20 25 years
to a point where doing data science was
not really considered
a real good career choice i you know i i
handled it in the
you know early 90s where being an expert
in data
you know just guaranteed one thing which
is very long
unemployment
[Laughter]
in 30 years time scale everything's
become fashionable that's my only
conclusion right
so i've come to an area which is now
considered ultra fashionable right
so i'll give you a personal 10 bit after
my phd
i started a startup and that's why
multiple startups
in my resume so people say look in 1994
when um you know doing startup was
unheard of
right and building something on here was
so um
uh considered so risky what motivated
you to go build a startup and my honest
answer has always been
you know the risk of the prospect of a
very long term and employment
usually is a great motivator and that's
exactly what motivated me to get started
right
but anyway data science is is is a hot
subject today
a couple of things will explode on the
top immediately right
one is business modeling i expect more
and more people to go into that area
because
there's a demand now there's more
disease modelers that you need epidural
molecular modular digital modelers you
name them
um people who tend to expect you know
understanding of pharmacokinetics and so
on right
the intersection of data and biology
will get sexy
right and that's been a trend for a
while it's just that it will get very
very hot
um secondary alcohol is what it calls
you know the whole area of uh call it
customer analytics or customer modeling
um as i said businesses will have to
come back
there's only two ways this business can
come back uh
one customers and two customers who
would preferably spend money with them
right
so unless you start understanding them
if that's usually
a good idea you know i understand that
in the world in the past seven eight
years
making money in a business was not
exactly a priority
but making money will soon become a
priority again so
understanding the entire customer
dynamics in the
constraints of what i just spoke about
three or four things right contactless
touchless hygiene and all of that stuff
will become extremely important right um
the third aspect um you know so the
whole customer
and in the customer journey customer
analytics
customer modeling customer behavior
modeling will just get a
new sort of uh fresh lease of life right
um the third aspect is going to be
the um just the businesses itself
will now start look at re-evaluating
the people they have um
in their workforce so a friend of mine
who has been in what i call the people
analytics class
hr hundred days uh i've talked to him
works with a large consulting company
and that's with a steady stream of
business right
nothing uh that sort of you know the
hottest thing in the market
they said look all of a sudden our
businesses are reaching out to us and
saying that look in a new world
how do i understand the nature of the
work itself is changing right
the working style is changing the way
people work from home or will do work
from a combination
of work and home itself is going to
change right
so how do you understand the impact of
that on the business and the
productivity right
that area is to me was you know
something that i
actually hadn't thought of until this
morning when i spoke to my friend
so the combination of what i call is a
work and people and business will be
itself i'm guessing is
start becoming a you know somewhat of a
hot area
the fourth any of the data scientists
will have to be evolved and that i had
touched upon before
but did not spend a lot of time on is
the digital skills right
because the world is going to be a
contactless world or largely a contract
go towards being more contactless unless
you understand
how the digital world sort of uh
merges with our physical world and the
interactions of that and the data it
produces and how to sort of build the
behavior
of uh people business etc out of that
world
you are going to be somewhat limited so
this is the four areas that i think
either one is the first of what is the
personalized business modeling second is
the whole aspect of customer modeling
third is what i call is the entire area
of people analytics right
and the fourth is digital this is the
four areas if you are taking a bet with
your carrier if you are 24 year old
um you know and come out of your masters
and if you're starting to think about
how the next 10 years would look like
uh these are the areas that you would
potentially explore i'm not suggesting
that other areas of data sciences are
not going to harm growth area
they're absolutely going to be but these
are the sort of the novel areas
in my you know in my state in my uh
opinion could see a you know quick surge
in the next few years
excellent um so as we keep
observing today the world has changed
um it's probably changed permanently and
so
an important question is what challenges
data scientists face in doing their work
what kind of obstacles does this
new world present um to doing your work
versus the way we were accustomed to
when we were all going into our offices
that you asked in the beginning of this
year so i write
on uh you know the
i have you know i write on medium i have
a reasonable number of
you know followers i get into debates
and all of that stuff
so one of the things i had predicted and
i can guarantee i had zero premonition
or
uh you know future information on this
at the last week of
2019 operations of 2020 i wrote that one
of the big shifts that's going to happen
in the data science
right is that then we shift on
delivering on your promises
data science you know if unless you work
for you know leave the
out
data science was the way of living data
science
was driving everything in there you know
and the data products were driving
everything
if you worked at a
you know most of the regular fortune 514
000 or regular businesses
data science was a novel thing right the
ceo knew that there was a group of
baseball people hanging on in the
company
they are doing some experiments you know
once it's really exciting news that
there is
a you know their recall and precision on
certain models have gone up
and the ceo the cfo and the cio would
pay it to that
there'll be once in a while articles
press releases on how great the company
is doing using this new technology
but in reality those are all experiments
right most cases
right uh i was looking at remember that
only 13
of the data science projects last year
actually so
that's right right it's a very low
number even lower than the id
because rightfully so it's not a failure
but rightfully so
it was the year we experimented 20 is
the year of delivery
right you are not going to be able to
not deliver
and keep building models so that right
it's a new challenge you'll be if you
are in data science
you better make sure you're working on
projects that have business impact
right not suggesting that experimental
or projects or exploration type of
projects would not be there
for uh youtube engaging right you'll
always be building fundamental stuff
that'd be useful few years from now
but the ratio of experiments versus
production
instead of being 85 15 or whatever 80 20
it will flip
lightly flip that's the first thing
right then the second
is the second shift is you know emphasis
on existing goals in the field right
what i mean by that
look when you someone says
you know i am a data scientist i am a
modeler right the business sort of
you know knows that you're very smart
guy but beyond that the business have no
idea what to do
right um today your ability to
now go and talk to i'm just you know
a marketing person right then
understanding uh in english
what did you do why do they run
campaigns what are the how to how do the
campaigns tie to the dollar that the
company brings right
think from that a marketing sales
whoever building your product
backwards to the products you need to
build
backwards to the modeling to build you
need to understand the whole thing
right you cannot be sitting in one
corner being a scientist
and sort of you know living in your
glories anymore unless you understand
the change
end to end you will actually fall behind
so these are the two
things that i would sort of consider as
new challenge
the let me flip it um also that question
and i'll take an additional sort of
opportunity right there will be new ones
being created
in the next few years and if you are a
young person especially right or even a
mid-career person
i would urge you to say look don't look
at is only as a new challenges
the challenges every challenge is an
opportunity people rise above the
challenge and make a name for themselves
right this is an
inflection point in all of your life
inflection points only come in once in
10 years when the u.s
economy goes through a cycle major
inflection point as
you are you know talking about intellect
right
come in once in 50 hundred you know
years
the major inflection point in the 20th
century the world economy was the first
world war and the second world war
and maybe two other things right it did
not you know the financial meltdown
was a uh you know maybe the third one
right this is a one in a hundred year
inflection point
take advantage of this right
um there have been new roles created
there will be new types of technologies
being developed there are new types of
problems
being solved go at the forefront of it
understand what you do
in the context of the society and the
development
and you'll be far more valuable in in
the next two to three years
because think of an inflection the way i
think of an inflection
is think of being a tsunami right the
waves look very daunting
but if you're on the top of the wave you
have
a great view of the world
yeah i was going to say that's a
wonderful metaphor because
it if you can surf the wave
you're you're in control of it and if
you can't surf the wave
it's in control of you absolutely
absolutely you know i'm not even a
swimmer but i always
marveled in california i always marveled
at the people who are riding on the top
of the waves
and you know now this is not gonna be a
tsunami and if you're a tsunami rider
you'll make a name for yourself you know
that's guaranteed
um the last question for discussion
is uh what kind of new skills
should data science practitioners um
adopt in order to ride that wave in
order to be prepared
you know to have their set of skills and
their surfboard ready
sure i'll take this example again what
happens after a tsunami
a tsunami comes to your land and you
know it flattens every house
right yeah which which is what you're
saying right this is
flat and a lot of livelihoods being lost
right what do you do after that
you rebuild you have to go you know you
go pick up your basic tools you pick the
hammer you pick the nail you put the
baseboard and build a house right so
just like that you are not going to now
go
design the skyscrapers because the
materials are just not available
it's going back to basics and rebuilding
everything
my answer for this would be just think
from that perspective
new skills that you need to reveal after
a tsunami of discuss
actually it's pretty simple that's why i
think the chance of successes are rather
high right
i would just take a contrarian view and
just unlearn
ml machine learning right what i mean by
that
is very simple if when we are sitting in
the corner of the labs and building
things toolkits on our own
we had plenty of time to go do things
that are crazy right everyone will try
to learn cnn and rnn
as if we are all of us are involved
self-driving car right
we are not most of our business problems
can be solved by simpler pro models
uh that fix most of the business
problems right
go figure that out right go get involved
with the business
use simpler toolkit your simpler
language
use simpler explanation
with the business to say look the
perspectives i have had always which is
our data scientist
is that you go to your business you are
the business saying look they're
struggling with the model saying that
this is not ending the results right um
you know um you know uh that way i'm
expecting
can you help because i don't know my
precision went up my recall went up and
my walk is a great one right
what are you talking about the guy is
thinking like one is
one is speaking in spanish the second
guy is speaking in push too
right it just doesn't work right so
pick up the simpler tool go win with
simple problems like wanting to make
friends and wanted to sort of help the
business
uh is essentially go solve the basic
problems help them get a few brownie
points few thousand dollars in revenue
and once the trust is built
scale it up right then it's in there
working in your tenure right
in terms of your skill set i would say
go back to basic
yet again both the advice are going back
to basic business slides
as well as skill set wise right i see a
lot of people spending a good
time trying to learn rule kids that are
complex right
that you know then you ask them the
simple thing what's the
minimum sample size for a two parameter
t test
they will struggle go back to the math
stats
probabilities and so on right the basic
stuff
understand look up the data in your hand
like look at the
you know understand data cleansing right
basic statistics on the data
why data is good what data is bad we
used to think
of a world when i was growing up we
spent 70 of the time in
in what i'd call the descriptive staff
basic math
data cleansing and so on model building
was only 10 20
because most of the world was modeled in
a simpler way right
go back to that it will actually ill
more resolve
business-wide than you can imagine and
once you have those wins right
in the next two to three years as the
world helps you be built
you will be essentially be the heroes
that the world will look up to right
very good that brings us to
the last question
or uh the last poll i should say
where we're going to ask people
what data science skills are you most
interested in adding
building on what utana just said
of the things that you look forward in
the post-covered world what are the
things that you want to add to your
toolkit
so that you're positioned to
so to speak rebuild the world after the
tsunami
so people are interested in uh data
analytics
but the largest number are interested in
ai and machine learning and
hear that and we're on to the question
and answer period
so uh we have a number of questions that
came
in from the audience and i will take a
look at those
and should i'll be asking you this
just a moment
so a lot of questions um
some companies are laying off
ai and ml engineers saying that the
previous data
developed hasn't proved useful could you
share your thoughts on that
so part of that is is you know and i can
tell you which companies right a part of
that is
is some of the natural business cycles
right uh if you recall in the
sort of at the 40th minute or so i said
a word
that you know making money had become
unfashionable
in the business world for the past seven
eight years you know and you can name
the companies all the new age companies
most of the unicorns in india and abroad
had gone through this uh in and funded
by and you know
a couple of vc and the t for you know
funds
that thought that shooting market share
at any cost was important and making
money wasn't
they hired a large number of people
right and the a lot of the data
scientists got hired there
uh sometimes they invaded universities
and hired the entire class
so part of that was just an excess
building up and shedding that extra
skill set
exceeds workforce right uh that's
natural
in any um event like this
uh that's expected it's a one in a
hundred year event
so that i would not worry about so what
ends up happening is that it's a sort of
a you know as i said it's a tsunami that
sort of goes and destroys the houses so
you're
seeing the pace of the house being
destroyed but the moment once it's sort
of done
in the short run in less than six months
you'll start seeing
that people getting redeployed and now
building the houses right which is
equivalent of data scientists being
deployed in
solving the types of problems that did
not exist before
so i would not worry about that as being
a phenomenon that
is going to be so unlike for example
i think your most of your audience is
way too young for that
y2k right yeah 2000 problem
there what happened was a very specific
problem that needed to be solved which
is the two digits of the computer
zero zero indicated uh you know when the
year 2000 reasons the computers would
not have
known what it meant right because the
computer
programs are not expected to last that
long
sure so there this very specific
workforce was deployed to go solve that
problem and then after that they sort of
became unemployed because the work had
a fixed timeline this is not like that
um the businesses will come back we'll
probably need
more data scientists in fact my bet is
that three things
will go very very grow very very fast
right
one is all things digital right
right uh second i call is all things
data
and third is automation right um
you know the world the way they are
being in if you have any of these
skill sets i just would not worry about
whether
you know some companies laid off machine
uh data scientist
i would however worry about one thing
though if you are not a true data
scientist
and uh you know someone who there's a
lot of people i know that
did not focus on what is what is that
the 50
second minute i said like focus on the
basics
if you did not have a match that
probably background if you didn't
understand data cleansing
and you saw i've just used a
something uh you know uh for from the
github
to go build your model or you just
looked up
uh someone else's work and sort of you
know built up that model without
understanding the fundamentals of that
then you're in trouble
if you did not do the hard work and sort
of got you know um
rode the wave in the last set of uh
irrational exuberance then you're in
trouble right
if you're the surfer who accidentally
rode away
because of the people who don't know how
to surf some will accidentally ride a
wave also
then you are prone to falling off
because now the waves seem much
much bigger than you could have handled
yeah
um building on that there are several
questions for people who are of
different backgrounds
mechanical engineering or uh finance
who are interested in
moving into data science and what are
the you know the basic
skills and tips for somebody who's
going to switch from one field
into data science
okay let me rephrase stuart because this
is where i
lost you it was a bit of a inaudible
so you're saying that um it's better now
so you're saying that if someone is
switching from other field into data
science what
how do they start right yeah what skills
do they need to have
and what what kind of a path do they
need to follow
so this actually this is reasonably
structured people
coming from other field right so other
field can be broken down into a music
one is what i'd call as a math and
science dominated field
and the second could be not dominated by
that you know engineering
uh etc but not math and science right
so for someone who is coming as for
example as a software developer
now wanting to so let's take two common
paths a software developer who is
wanting to go to data science right the
path
typically i would uh i believe firmly in
the world of building a bridge right
which is your is your skill sets that
you have in existence right
apply that in a new field that's the
bridge to get into the vehicle and then
acquire the skills underneath and then
sort of build your house right
so there i would say there is uh one
two ways to do it right either you go
through the path of being
a data analytics person which is build
the skills on
you know tableaus dashboarding basic
data analysis
because in that process you end up
picking up the other skills that you
needed some maps
that and so on which sort of prepares
you for that if you are in data
engineering skill
it allows you to deal with two things
right one is the scale and understanding
how the data pipelining works and so on
and so on right
so from engineering you could either go
as you know try to switch to a data
engineer
or try to switch to a data analytics
and then eventually once you're getting
better neither of them there could be a
path to data side
not always because you have to be
on the other hand if you are coming from
i call it
math staff probabilities physics and so
on right
those but have not done a lot of
sort of what i'd call the engineering
enterprise grade engineering
my answer to that would be just focus on
computer science courses right
uh and coding you have to code i mean
you know i haven't seen any other
scientists
uh you know the people who are saying oh
i you know their new
uh uncode uh or no coding or low coding
data science models
uh the data science approaches that
could help you get an
assigned job yes those are there i
understand automl and the other stuff
but they're not there yet right it's not
and unless you're an expert in data
science itself
don't go into sort of you know it comes
almost in a reverse order you become an
expert in data science and then you sort
of grow pick up the low code or no code
approaches because you understand
fundamentally what it does
so if you are coming from those like
this what is the science path
the one your approach should be go
understand coding go understand work in
engineering
then use your leverage which is the map
and science background you now go
uh and some algorithm background uh to
go build
a carry and data science i could have
literally drawn that path that lie
is reasonably well defined
you just have to make sure you follow
that back um
someone asks uh what's your opinion of
somebody becoming a
combination digital marketing expert and
data scientist
is that a good combination
it's actually not a bad combination it's
actually a pretty good combination i
touched upon that somewhere in the
middle of the conversation saying that
you have to understand
what the digital mark so for example
when you said digital marketing
expert i'm assuming you're not saying
that i'm an expert in
seo and sem can i become a data
scientist because that's
not i'd recommend but if you understand
the digital marketing
how digital channel works how data
pipelining works
how does the app work what's the
notification in an app
how advertise the cards in an app if you
understand those aspects
those are extremely valuable stream sets
in a data scientist right i wish i had
data scientists
would actually understand like the app
world
much better than they do today right now
that is understandable but if you are
thinking that s-u-s-e-m expert
doing keywords and then want to go to
data scientists i don't think there's a
great connect
i mean you're just starting fresh
um this is what
an american slang is called inside
baseball this is a
question it's very specific how is data
science and artificial intelligence
applied
in improving business performance intel
for increasing the average revenue per
user
is that something you want to discuss or
is that a trade secret
i cannot disclose that's the one
question i cannot take i should have
said it beforehand
that anything related to you know my
current employer is actually off the
record we have a regulated industry
and i cannot answer that because it
could be seen as an you know
insider information so i cannot answer
that yeah i figured that
there might be an obstacle with that
question but i wanted to
let the user know that that we had
received it um
i think that's pretty much all the time
we have for
uh questions and so
um what i'd like to do then is
go ahead and say thank you to to
antonio for um joining us
let me uh share with everyone the
okay bye ending off that's right
i just wanted to thank everyone in the
audience thank you again
um it's been a pleasure interesting set
of questions
uh hopefully you get to you know i
remember
you know i was you know at one time i
was 25 26
uh wondering about the world what to do
next as i said
my world was rather bleak because i was
an expert in data
uh but you know the world has changed so
i would say
a couple of things right one do things
you know whatever you do be passionate
about it just sort of my closing
comments
number one number two the field that
you're in today and if you're interested
in data science that will is just going
to grow exponentially so don't worry
about
the next 5 10 20 years just focus
yourself in understanding things
at a base level number three i tell
everyone
enjoy it right if you're not having fun
doing whatever you are doing
don't do it like you're better off being
something else just don't jump into it
because
all your friends blackmails
neighborhoods and in india
uncle and after asking you that you
should go do data science i've heard
that
you know i have had i have had one
gentleman one young man coming saying
that look i really don't want to breathe
i said why did you like call everyone
why did your entire family call me for
an internship
because my uncle wants me to do the data
science my father wants me to
don't do it not for the right reason
don't do it you should enjoy things that
you do
uh with that i'd like to again thank you
for
people everything everywhere from united
states
africa india and my friends and
philippines all these are wonderful
countries i've been to
about 40 countries around the planet
people around the planet
are wonderful uh everyone stay safe
stay at home we are going to get through
this one uh
collectively and the world is going to
be a better world five years from now
uh you will all forget about what
happened will not forget it will be in
my
you know memory but we'll uh largely be
overcoming most of the hardship we have
had
stay safe wire mask if you can if you
i and you should wear a mask and and if
you can
limit your travel to the uh essentials
you know that will help prevent the uh
outbreak and
you know it will get us over the hump as
quickly quicker than we would do
otherwise
thank you thank you
very much we really appreciate your time
today you can
get in touch with us through our social
media channels
uh facebook twitter and linkedin
and that concludes today's webinars
again thanks everybody
bye-bye
you